if you want to get in so bad why do you
think it's so long Joe Concha writes
about the media for everyone that asks
especially they hell he joins us now
live from a studio which is very close
to his house hey Joe first off is it
surprising he got such positive reviews
after three weeks ago the you know the
touchy-feely Joe didn't really explain
himself too well surprising is that a
rhetorical question Brian I believe it
is yeah look the view amazingly falls
under ABC's news division that's not
even seen as an entertainment show so
I'll just leave that there and I watched
this interview today and I didn't hear
any questions in terms of who is Joe
Biden he has been in politics for nearly
40 years and I honestly don't know what
at what's at his core and in the end
Hillary Clinton made this mistake
because we saw that in those clips that
you played as a Democrat you can't just
say Donald Trump's a bad guy I'm a good
guy or in Hillary's case a good woman
and if you vote for me that's good
enough no people want to know what
you're gonna do to improve their lives
what's his position in terms of
improving health care immigration the
opioid crisis in terms of raising taxes
will you raise taxes or not raise taxes
what's your position on infrastructure
and so on so I want to hear those
questions I don't want to see what I saw
today I'm not surprised by it there are
actually two Republicans that are on
that panel and I get with Megan McCain
why she would want to endorse Biden
considering her father's relationship
with mr. Biden but at the same time look
he's gonna have to do some interviews
with some tough people in some tough
places if he expects to be president
United States and answer the kind of
questions that I would pose was I just
laid out just now Joe look he's been in
the business for 36 years since he was
28 years old I get it's gonna be tough
maybe he's a decision you made in 1984
you wouldn't make in 2019 totally
understandable but if Donald Trump
teaches you anything it's don't run from
it embrace it explain it but don't
apologize for it
I'm not sure what he's doing about too
controversial things they need a hill
situation as well as the touchy feeling
trend he hasn't really apologized he
addressed it and the other thing he did
he mocked right after he addressed it
and is poorly done instantly
video so so far in term of damage
control you can't give him an A oh no
you can he has been in crisis mode
for the past two months before he even
ran right and with Anita Hill I mean
doesn't anybody on the view or anybody
else who interviews him going forward
didn't anybody find that completely
disingenuous that only after he
announced that he decides to apologize
to Anita Hill what was that
nearly 30 years ago he hasn't had the
time since then or even what he was
running for vice president so to do that
now and say hey I'm running for
president I think I feel bad about what
I did I'm sorry that comes across his
phone and what we've learned at least
from Donald Trump winning Brian is that
people embrace authenticity good and bad
or ugly but be authentic don't be that
guy and what happened is he picked up
the phone he called the Nita hill it's a
disaster she gave an interview to the
New York Times who said I don't I
essentially don't accept his apology and
didn't really apologize
what are they upset about he didn't vote
for Clarence Thomas what did he do
evidently he didn't tell the truth
according to her about when she'd get to
testify it was not gonna be first she
was she thought it was last she wasn't
allowed to bring up people to verify her
story so just go out and explain what
you were doing as chairman with the
Republican nominee and move on because
nobody wants to relitigate we barely
remembered the story I'm not saying it
wasn't important but if you're a
politician and you have a staff and he's
got money he should be able to answer
these questions I mean the other 19
contenders aren't seeing the undefeated
heavyweight champ right now and good for
knee to hell by the way for not falling
in line and doing what she was supposed
to do which was accepted so Joe Biden
can get past this hurdle look for people
that are worried that Joe Biden's going
to get a free ride from the media Brian
here's all you need to know before the
2016 election 59 papers major ones
offered their endorsements 57 went to
Hillary Clinton
two went to Donald Trump that got
Hillary Clinton a concession speech so
that's all you need to know in terms of
influence of our media today at least on
the political side and look the bottom
line is that as far as the media putting
their finger on the button for Joe Biden
we saw it obviously with Hillary Clinton
it simply doesn't work as half the
country
does not trust the messenger it's all
white noise the Punda tree and the
predictions mean nothing to the American
people they'll decide what happens here
from debates and a concise message which
Biden needs to establish besides Trump
is a bad guy and Joe I gotta let you go
but one of the you understand how
controversial it's going to be for him
when he did not know how to greet the
hosts he said I didn't know what to do
to shake your hand to give you a hug to
give you a kiss because we're friends
but with Joe with Joe Biden to win in
2019 he can't be Joe Biden that could be
a problem
show your release to go party and go to
the club is right near your house like
you do every Friday night it appreciate
it in Jersey there's nothing like it
Brian quite for him in Hatton you'll get
yourself in trouble
Joe concha probably